Our challenge is to lead a new era
of global prosperity. We have reached
agreements to reduce
gas emissions from polluting industries. We have
also moved towards
sustainable air transport. We have approved several
pioneering regulations that will
help us better reuse waste and
have products.  more durable, more
repairable and more recyclable and we have
achieved and in this I also want to thank
the work of the European Parliament
something very important for this
presidency and it is a nature restoration law
and we have also
presented a common front in
the cop28 negotiations a
conference that today has
announced to us the end Or at least the abandonment
of fossil fuels which I think
is one of the best news that we
could have received and from Dubai in
these unions I also want to extract
others such as for example the
start-up  of the disability card
the development of new directives to
combat structural violence in
all European societies such as
violence against women and trafficking
in human beings and to expand the rights
of other vulnerable groups
many problems remain to be resolved And many
injustices  I mention them to correct
so that we are aware of our
enormous potential so that we understand that
it is possible to build a Europe with
leading companies with clean and
cheap energy with full employment with
decent wages with good public services and
with a better standard of living for the
social majority